let me explain why creating spec work
that you want to be paid to create is so
important as a motion designer by
creating work that you love to make
you're putting your passion and
creativity on display for the world to
see and the best part is someone might
see that work and hire you to create
something similar when you create spec
work that you're proud of it becomes a
part of your portfolio and your demo
reel this helps you showcase your skills
and style to potential clients and
employers and as more people see your
work and hire you to create similar
pieces you'll continue to get paid to do
what you love this creates an endless
cycle of creating work that you enjoy
making and getting better at your craft
so go ahead create the work that
inspires you and let your creativity and
passion shine